The Joe Rogan experience.
What you don't hear only on Tucker Carlson. I don't know how that happened.
Is anyone criticizing the pharmaceutical industry,
the number one advertiser in all media's pharmaceutical industry,
you will not see. So it's you it's CNN.
Can't criticize the vaccines because, and they're advertising. Yeah.
They get calls. It's,
it's built on advertising and it's easier to discredit someone.
Uh, because when you say this guy is, uh, is a horrible person, right?
Advertisers run away from that. They don't want, this is,
it has no different than Twitter or YouTube.
It's not really about political opinions.
Political opinions can leverage the advertiser relationship to get someone
canceled. Right. That's the mechanism. So this has become so good now.
And you know, like, what are they called? Sleeping giants and media matters.
And all these types of groups who organize. I mean,
I haven't seen it on podcast index. I've got a whole thing, Tim. Dylan sucks.
You have to get him off. He's a home. MAOB, he's a racist. He's a Transo.
And then I'll see that, you know, five other guys who have podcasting 2.0 apps.
They have the same, the same note. Now there's no advertising.
So we're all like, whatever. Have you wait.
A minute, hold on. Have you really seen something that says, Tim,
Dylan's a homophobia? Oh yeah. He's gay.
I'm just telling, of course I'm just know how crazy that is.
Are you asking me if the world has gone insane, Joe.
But the fact that they wanna say that Tim Dylan's a homophobic cause he makes
fun of gay people. He is actually gay.
Yeah. I didn't know that I don't care.
But he's openly gay discusses.
It all the time. But the point is it's to leverage. This is,
and this is okay where this all comes from. Ultimately I think is again,
the prob money, corrupts money is the root of all evil.
And, uh, right now we're in a position where the global banking system,
which is far from removed from even anything you and I can really understand
how credit works and how there's $400 trillion worth of that
surrounds the bond markets. It's all just, it's an illusion. Um,
in order to, uh,
<laugh> in order to keep the control, um,
we have to utilize this at every single moment.
We have to use it as a wedge for everything.
And all of these companies are nothing more than a, a part of that system.
Hmm. They are the,
the money flows through everything and it's most of its advertising base.
All of Silicon valley is, is a hits business. Uh, instead of carry what,
what your users want. They want hits. So they'll acquire hits, oh, this is this,
this YouTube's great. We're gonna help hook 'em up. Uh,
this podcast cast is great. We're gonna give 'em 60, 80, a hundred million,
no offense, but it's hits business. They're buying hits,
not doing anything more than that. And if you don't play along,
you're going to lose your income overnight. So ESG, have you heard of this?
No. Environmental, uh, I feel like to have a drink. You wanna have a drink?
I'd love a drink, especially when they get into ESG intense. No,
but the ESG is fascinating. Bring some glasses in. Yeah.
So ESG and, and this is now something that if you want to invest in a company,
they will on their investor relations page. They'll show you the at ESG score,
ESG stands for environmental social corporate governance.
And this is where the woke culture comes from.
So they've created this kind of phony baloney rating system that says, well,
if you I'm, I'm exaggerating. But if you mention that you are, you know, uh,
have a green agenda and you,
and you believe in carbon credits and you might trade some credit somewhere,
then you get a higher score and therefore you're more investible.
And it's very interesting to see how big investors like insurance company,
institutional investors,
they are steering away from anything that does not have the right ESG rating.
And so in order to, uh, have investors continue to be interested in the stock,
which is important for the company, for its perception, certainly for the, uh,
the officers of the company and the shareholders, uh,
you have to move this, move this along continuously.
And so it's very simple to see why doing a woke ad as Nike or as
any other company. Um, and, and, uh,
pride month is fantastic because you could, pride is easy,
throw up some flags show, the right people, trends, whatever, right?
And then you got a high ESG score.
And so this is a control mechanism that is being used throughout all
corporations worldwide. And I don't even think it's stoppable.
People are just starting figure out what's going on.
That's where all this is coming from. Nike.
Doesn't give a about black people that way. I don't believe it.
They care about their stock price. Of course,
individually there's people who care. There's no doubt about it,
but it's driven by ESG. It is the,
and so it kind of started with the DEI,
the diversity equity inclusion that has now moved over to, um,
and you can look it up. SASB, SASB,
that's the board of standards and statistics for corporations,
and they have this formula, how you measure, uh, your ESG score.
And if you're really investible. And it's funny because you'll see,
like Nike has a 75% score Tesla,
which you think would be really good eight because you know,
not woke enough or Elon, you know, says the wrong things.
So it's actually harder to invest, uh,
for institution to invest in Tesla because of their low ESG score. Really?
Mm-hmm <affirmative> huh? Yeah. This is, this is some,
I'm just really learning about this myself.
How did you find out about this ESG stuff? Ah, kidneys, brother do kidneys.
<laugh> you don't remember that joke? No, holy. You're my age. No.
What is the joke from? I, it was old joke. It's like some moronic kid in school,
you know, figured it out. And then, uh, it's like, Hey, how come?
You're not a moron? The moron says, uh, kidneys, kidneys. Oh, what, what?
It was on that doesn't quite work. What was that on?
Was that.
A joke on? That was when I was in third.
Grade. Oh, like a joke joke. Yeah. Like, oh, like two Jews walking to a bar.
That kind of a joke.
Yeah. Only less offensive.
Is that offensive? Well, the joke,
the Jews joke is they buy it two Jews walking a bar, they buy it. Yeah.
Boom shot lock. It's not.
So this ESG stuff is really being utilized to control.
Ah, it. So society, society in general and,
and Twitter has to adhere to the same thing.
And they're using it as a method to maximize profits because people will support
companies that are woke because it aligns with their own person value.
So the companies espouse.
I wouldn't say profits, I would say shareholder value. Okay.
That's a little different than profit.
Why, what, what is the difference between profit.
And shareholder? Well, this is so currently,
if you are a CEO and you have a board and everyone has stock and all your
C-suite people, and you're important, people all, all have shares and uh,
the way the mechanism works, all right,
we have the federal reserve and interest rate is at zero.
So big companies can go to any bank or, uh,
and literally federal reserve is the bank to and say,
I need a hundred billion and they're gonna give it to me for almost 0%.
You know, cuz what we pay on credit card interest or something.
That's not what banks pay. They pay almost nothing.
So they get that free money and uh, then they buy back their stock buying back.
Their stock makes the price rise.
Everybody who has stock wins that has been going on for a long time.
That's that's,
that's the number one way of getting really rich in a public company, apple,
you know, this was the thing when Trump had is repatriation of the money and,
and also the, uh, the corporate tax cut. The main thing, that was a problem.
And I'm not sure how they dealt with it was, well, you're getting all this,
you you're bringing this money into the country, uh,
or you're getting a tax break.
We don't want you just using it to reinve to buy your own shares.
Cuz you buy your own shares.
You're only making yourself wealthy off of actually the backs of the American
people because we didn't get that tax revenue. Mm.
And that's the system how it's worked and now they're just expanding it into
this E this mythical ESG. And you know, it's based on how, how green you are,
uh, you know, net zero aspirations reports, wokeness, uh,
social justice.
And it's also because it's connected to the idea of being a better person.
It's so easy to support. God love it, brother, look at the ads.
And it's one of the rare times where a corporation will get support from the
general public for yeah. For sticking with, because, because.
We're good people. Yeah. And we all believe we're good people. People,
I love it. I want my,
my L G B T Q L G B B T Q Q I a P plus two BS.
Bye. And by curious, that's.
In there too, by curious in my version, there is,
is H in there yet just overall horny <laugh> can't people just isn't that
pansexual. Are they in there? I, I love.
I find it so insulting that, you know, it's called the LGBTQ community.
It's not a community. It's just as insulting as the black and brown community.
Oh, what zip code do I go to, to meet some black and brown community people.
It's really, that to me is offensive. I hate that. But anyway,
so it's so good to have that group. And by the way, the LS don't like the GS,
the GS have problem with he's. I mean, all this that's a great, um, uh,
Chappelle bit actually. Right, right, right. Yeah. The alphabet people. Yeah.
He's, he's spot on with that spot on. It's not a community, but anyway,
it's such a, it's being abused. Um, just as, uh, black lives matter,
ink, not black lives matter. The feeling is good people cuz we're good people.
We don't want racism. We don't want people hurt. We don't want people, um,
discriminated against, but we're being used like ponds and saying, oh,
well then do this and go here and say yes to this. And then before you know, it,
you're kind of stuck in the system where you're afraid to say that's not okay.
Yeah. And for me, it's the simplest saying,
I do not believe in an L G B T community.
I believe in people and they do their own thing and they love who they love and
do what they want. And that's one thing mm-hmm, <affirmative>,
it's not a community that you can put together and say,
this is what we're doing for them. Right. Right.
And I think trans women are the most abused by corporations.
Now they're using 'em everywhere and every ad and you know, just to,
just to push and push and push well.
It's just because it's in Vogue. Right. So this is something that.
Latch on in Vogue or ESG. Yeah.
They, they latch on to, to, but of course, what does it.
Stand for again, en environmental social corporate, uh, goals,
a governance I'm sorry. Governance, environmental, social corporate governance.
Catch new episode owes the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog JRE videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save data cost all for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.